hey are you busy and writing Star Trek
fan fiction does not count
hahaha finished it last week what's
going on um I miss Andy and you probably
miss your lover Chris wait I had an idea
it's Friday pawnees only a 10 hour drive
road trip oh I don't know it's gonna try
and get a jump on some work this weekend
dude 30 years from now when you're on
your deathbed what are you gonna
remember organizing files or taking a
spontaneous road trip to surprise Leslie
yeah you know what all right I'm in you
know we might be able to sneak out early
you get snacks
I'll bring music we'll jam out to some
sweet to niche you know what this is
awesome actually no I don't want to go
anymore
oh okay just kidding see you in 10
minutes okay just kidding we're not
going road trip so we're going yes oh
I'm excited to bond a little with April
she's like the little sister I never had
because the little sister I do have is
normal and not terrifying
good lord
it is hot yes Mercy Me living in this
town's life living in the devil's butt
crack almost out of gas
heito we're on the highway the GPS says
we should take 495 to 270 but check out
this cool alternate route right that is
so interesting to me because I'm a map
salesman why aren't we moving because
other cars will you not do that don't do
when you stoked it oh great here comes a
guy excuse me
why aren't we moving exits closed for a
bit presidential motorcade just shut off
the car till it opens up holy it's hot
soundtrack to Pulp Fiction soundtrack to
Singles soundtrack to Grosse Pointe
blank why do you have so many
soundtracks oh well I can't look at it
like it's your favorite directors making
a mixtape just for you oh oh here's
something Benji is cool time summer jams
mix oh no I probably don't want to
listen to that data had never felt this
way before
of course data had never felt anything
before but Captain Picard couldn't help
but note the smile that crept over his
mechanical but lifelike face I'm gonna
murder you I understand just one second
as they walked down the hall into the
bridge
well it's moving it's moving what yes
finally
no no no no what no we're out of gas
please just steer be stronger
that's a great road trip we made it 40
feet yeah well at least it took a
million hours and it was 180 degrees and
we starve to death so fine hey how about
next weekend we fly to Pawnee tickets
are on me
really that would be awesome definitely
yeah never mind I don't feel like it
what oh my god see how it feels
you